hello lianas trailer commentary for
total recall this is the show where
we'll talk about our thought process and
our deeper deeper insights the 1990 film
Arnold Schwarzenegger film if you stick
around we're gonna watch a trail
together then you'll see some cut jokes
afterwards we'll respond to some viewer
comments and questions
yeah well tease next week's honest
trailer yeah it's a 1990 film but it
feels very 80 a lot of it is very aged
might have been one of the last 80s
movies true eighties yeah this is lon
Harris Dan morrow
unfortunately Daniel Radford isn't here
today and she did most of the work on
this one
but well you know she's not here so
we'll talk about instead if this duo
hadn't caught fire she would have been
here on that day we just mean we would
have been able to record this on the
usual day not that Daniel she's doing
well anyways this movie I was gonna
swear this was good this is like a
longtime favorite I know what most
people like you're like what is the
quintessential Arnold movie hmm this is
not I don't think the best one but if
you ever want to point to like what was
Arnold Schwarzenegger at his peak good
and bad yep it's this movie yeah
like the just like he's not all good
he's not all bad he's like this is right
in the middle of like the best and worst
of arles words yeah it's something about
the combination of his sensibility and
paul verhoeven together is that's the
magic of total recon something I don't
think we managed to put in the trailer
is how long Eraserhead
come on what's his name you know not
David Lynch Cronin Cronenberg yes I'm
sorry
scanner yes how long Cronenberg was
developing this and how many things that
aren't in the the Phil Caidic story made
its way in that are so Cronenberg and
act just like a weird gross touch to
this yeah the mutants apparently are all
that was a Cronenberg
original concept and Wow does that feel
Cronenberg II and I guess Arnold loved
this concept and wanted and like he had
to buy it himself to get it developed
and got to pick his director and
everything because this also the story
stars like a mild-mannered office worker
who wants an escape from his his desk
job and but when you cast our first
Nagar yeah make my instruction or two
budgeted the trailer is like it's the
future but only the two things that we
have that are super futuristic er
interstellar travel we could go to
anywhere in the solar system yeah and we
can mess around with your brain and then
you give you memories or steal your
memories otherwise all technology is
frozen in 1992 televisions yeah I just
okay because some things were just
taking for granted that they exist today
like automated cars yes they also have
robot robot but not self-driving cars
they still need the robot driver there
right Johnny cab like everything else is
just like well it just looks like today
nothing changed yeah true they have that
wall that they eat breakfast in front of
that's a big TV hologram canister that's
we fit it looks like a display you would
see it fries it doesn't that look like a
hundred years from now that's what our
Holograms would be like I'll be
disappointed if our holograms are like
that andand reduce yeah but I would like
to I'd rather live in the 80s version of
the future than today the present
there's a lot of dystopian garbage that
they're havin didn't predict I mean
apparently they're the subway that they
take is just Mexico City's subway which
I guess looks well futuristic like they
didn't really do anything to it it
doesn't really look cool CRT panel
displays all over that subway it's got
cool angles yeah yeah
the future was was angled sure is angled
things would be angled very different
2019 why are we not all wearing shoulder
pads I do love this marriage though of
just like Paul Verhoeven and his like
scalp scalpel like a social lighting you
know satire and just aren't squirts a
like the biggest just blunt
objects sledgehammer that you can throw
at anything no subtle dwells we can
discuss that let's look at the trailer
the first thing to talk about yeah yeah
I didn't work on this full disclosure so
I'm gonna do it Arnold did in the actual
commentary for Total Recall at the
beginning just narrate what's happening
so you can see what it's like yes thank
you everyone on Mars Total Recall buzz
well first of all the good one did
anyone see at this table - Colin Farrell
one
it's the one thing I like that they do
is that they changed a lot it doesn't
feel like they're just wrote redoing the
exact like they're taking a lot of
inspiration from it the other good thing
that they did is Bryan Cranston's
perfect casting is ko Haig mmm aces but
it doesn't really work as like an action
sci-fi I heard they took out the mutants
the TL Richter yeah it's very it's very
different it's it's political but in a
different like it's different polylines
of politics yes it's like the filthy
dick stories oh yeah which takes us to I
really I don't think sorry that this
Total Recall and then they just win a
different even different way with it's
also like Len Wiseman directed and I
just you don't get the same so it was
blue yeah it was very
you don't get to say you know it's just
not visually arresting in the way that
the original was like the original so
idiosyncratic and of itself and they
just made it like another dividuals
carry the runway as kind of the last
movie now as I'm sure it's not class but
it's like it really had a mix of
practical and CG yeah when they really
couldn't rely on one or the other
yeah and I think that he plays it
beautifully but Paul Verhoeven we call
him the king of having his cake and
eating it - mm-hmm which i think is both
what i love about him and a appropriate
critique if you will of his movies of
like he's he's almost insulting to his
audience which is something that I you
know respect he's like he's like you
want to see this don't you like you
idiots don't you think isn't this what
you want but I'm gonna heighten it to
such an extent that I'm making fun of it
it is Kai I mean easily European so
you're getting that like this is a
European artist coming and reacting to
suddenly working in America and that
really threads its way through all of
the American movies is that they're all
kind of on some level parodies of the
United States of America especially
showgirls showgirls is really like
that's just him making fun of us for two
hours I like showgirls a lot but yeah I
so over the top of this depiction of
Americans like literally eating dog food
right I think he's a simpleton he thinks
it's funny
but Elizabeth Berkeley thinks it's dead
serious and Joe Esterhaus is like you
know ten eight balls deep and things of
the greatest thing on earth Gina Gershon
knows exactly yes movies or at least all
of his American movies have that tension
cuz like Starship Troopers kind of has
it too like Denise Richards and Casper
Van Dien aren't playing it funny they're
playing it very straight source material
plays it completely sprite but he's kind
of doing that like his Beverly Hills
90210 and out of space like he's got
that sort of self-aware sound - I love
them yeah I do - yeah good guy
yes sir he's weird Bush scrap it for a
mind-bending trip to the future that's
going through a big 90s retro crazy Park
says Biden no real vacation
the robots took our jerbs going outside
will kill you
great prosthetics these days right
then we really know we were in a
dystopia Oh pause that was on shark tank
this past weeks ago one of those exact
ones was instructing does it get you
high it well well one of the reasons the
trouble wasn't on shark tank was that
that exact question was it was it was
pitched for like use for if you need it
but also it's like but at the same time
it is supposed to be like for clarity
and focus do you remember there was like
this exact fad was a thing like 20 years
ago
Woody Harrelson had like an O bar yeah
this was gonna be a thing and then it
went away and now it's gonna be a thing
again now we need it because there have
to be huffing yeah I love celebrity
vanity like Hobby projects like doesn't
is it Susan Sarandon that has a
ping-pong bar downtown Wow
yeah I believe it I just couldn't get I
couldn't because like the thing that I
saw had the mask and so they're like use
it and they're like all the Sharks just
going too much Wow I just what's the
best made-up movie drug for me it's
Robocop - just the little patches you
put on your eyes you have
I like what the the Minority Report one
where it's like the little thing there
in the little button goes down it just
looks cool oh yeah you know what do you
like so higher Xin your mouth I'm just
curious about death sticks on ik name
putting the name death in your drug it
could go either way it sounds dangerous
but maybe people think they're gonna die
yeah won't be the only one let's play a
man you can't tell fantasy from reality
like some other Quaid you may know it's
easy there a Mindwipe super spy with the
key to saving Mars in his brain or a
construction worker who married Sharon
Stone so yes two equally unlikely
options but when quiet paused I think
they did a good job of keeping it pretty
ambiguous whether it was a dream or not
I think it was a dream I usually don't
like that in movies but I think it works
really well here yeah I think it was too
right I think as soon as he's getting
drowsy at recall that's where that's
where it kicks in yeah I am inclined to
go the other way until the very end like
the very last shot to me I feel like is
almost too much of a giveaway because he
turns there he goes I was like oh I just
had a terrible thought what if this is
all a dream and then the Sun like
explode like the whole screen fades to
white from the Sun and I feel like well
that's him waking up
that's the when you have a dream and
then you think about oh I'm in a dream
that's the moment that you wake up and
what we're seeing is him opening his
eyes and the lights and recall coming on
and the dream is over
yeah went very go ambiguous you you tell
me I decide maybe it's all real thanks
baby
they didn't one thing you would be like
should we ask him if he wants the guy's
arms to get ripped it's really gross and
you do other people who order that
scenario also ripoff
like everybody who's going on the Mars
spy adventure has this bloody it's an
extremely grim adventure yeah so such
big squids every time I shoot some I
feel like they would want to prepare you
like do you want the pg-13 to get pretty
gruesome see I think it's definitely a
dream because there's one point I think
the shots even in this trailer where
he's just karate chops a guy is forehead
are they useing is these are these
future guns that's why everyone explode
squibs they use this mr. big four times
the size of a convention we think the
grip people's clothes bars has lower
gravity in their future guns inside the
dome it happens at Robocop 2 though 9
the guy that gets hit especially in the
extended clothes are just wired bullets
ripping you apart
not just people getting shot yeah I
[Music]
think for once somebody in the comments
actually had a good joke they said we
should have just said it's not a tumor
like this that's kind of kind of fits
better than it it's just about it's just
a boner like Bona and to kind of rhyming
in that context is funny well we have
about 700 outtakes for that so get ready
for this I wonder a short Sager what
he's a dr has to do like a few minutes
of arnold sounds yes
[Music]
well hustle with this wife Laurie
a highly-skilled processes if you were
planning Arnold that'd be your only job
Mars governor who sent Quaid to earth
with a false identity surrounded by
actors waited for him to discovery
someone else assumed he'll go to more
searching for vengeance send a friend a
very particular cab driver and earn the
trust of the mutant resistance leader or
none of his evil plan works frankly I
mean just like he's one of those guys
from the 80's and 90's particularly he's
been good as a lot of difference doesn't
like it he's just like oh my god Ronny
Cox and also Michael Ironsides is in
that yeah I love that barrel that has
like a troupe of actors yeah a vendor
with his gang like he's got some of the
best yeah it's there it's more realistic
and like gives you a movie more depth
when we're very into like relatable
villains you know like Marvel movies
there's always gonna be like you can see
from the villains perspective they have
a point and I like that there's a lot of
eighties who reserved they're just like
nah he's just out of bastards lazy and
evil best like william atherton used to
play a little dice it was just the worst
I think there's no redeeming Gua no man
at all when he falls off this building
though and Ghostbusters he had a point
and I'm
but he's a jerk about it
it's a jerk enough to make you a villain
in the ad yeah yeah good
environmentalism yeah
teacher like the the corporate Toy Story
PA stuck in middle management who in one
day has to let way to his wife decorated
by his boss and lose both of his arms oh
I hope this is all a dream and rigors
just some guy who spit and quit drinking
at Chili's or something Space Jam matrix
with its red pills reality bending and
firefight with riot cops and a roomful
of pillars and influenced avatar with
this double agent who fights for the
colonized people falls in love with one
of them meets their psychic leader then
accidentally leaves the bad guys to the
rebels hold up I just ripped off fun
going but no matter how the discerning
cinephile will recognize it for what it
is a total ripoff of the greatest sci-fi
film ever made
spaceball Spaceballs lately one of my
favorite movies ever made work so good
mega maid she's gone yeah we will deal
with your rebel friends soon enough
Richter and Morty goodbye try a parent
spared Mars hard he's named at the die
hard private uh scars this is a dystopia
yeah yeah should be a setting hon beat
all the apps don't talk to me yes yeah
why would you make Johnny cab there's
nobody likes that nobody wants to do
banter driver you would never invent
that no
not a thing what if we have a cab driver
but he does bits all well any Hooper in
Los Angeles yeah that's what we want to
get rid of that's what they need to fix
yeah John Johnny keV wanna hear my
mixtape that happened to me you like
this song and I'm like yeah it's pretty
good like do you know who it is I was
like I know the answer this question is
who it's me put on like a Radian like a
Travis Scott soccer sound like a radio
song who's like you like this sure it's
like trying to be nice
and he's like oh well if you like that
you'll like this music I gotta now I
have to buy I'm gonna spend $12 on your
LP unbelievable yeah really toyed with
deleted scenes from our trailer for
Total Recall see we did it we work in
the free food matrix right the top we're
card in that third view and we don't
want you to wait for it have both kinds
of heat what you've been feeding this
thing that's my sock ah still a penis
baby as my sponsor do you want to leave
right in the stones too late
mm-hmm and fight Ricker a literal sake I
mean isn't that the definition like I
bet he's watching another man with his
wife yes that's the literal definition
of the dictionary for cuck its Richter
technically space so bumbling
boomers should be posting Richter beams
on face Corey the reactor forget me
shots the Quaid Redemption Houser of a
thousand voices American Hauser's Wow
does this guy look like a dub to use and
done van horn here creepily accurate
animatronic Arnold
[Music]
Sharon right in the stones Wow two
verses he mention yeah Lots
a very wrong engagement my wife
romancing the stove by Wallace and the
real girl I just met a girl named Alina
hi rebel it is a tumor Chuckie Fodor
boss baby young boys about sex before
internet porn Oh three boob trees
mammary president's groove cohaagen with
mr. Richter higher side pants the rigor
fail white boy Richter Uncle Tom's Cabin
[Laughter]
yeah Mars attack red planet heat mm-hmm
Ziggy Stardust Memories okay memoirs I'm
an invulnerable man the air down there
[Music]
when he wakes up does he just go back to
his wife like he doesn't remember
shooting her in the head
oh well there you go big thank you to
Robert Hopi for I forgot to pare it down
before it was sent to our graphics
person who then I guess it's like 20
versions of it but they were all
apparently the last minute cuz he helped
me on Sunday say like hey you have the
graphics oh no oh yeah see didn't you
leave and everything falls apart
Shmuel down what's go down I guess love
to watch you people have had some
thoughts but what
there's the Hank Schrader thing yeah a
lot of comments about a yes and we
didn't know that just forgot to put his
in right we just didn't include any of
the jokes like if they're Martian
minerals Murray was one of them well sex
Raider just called him a hunk
yeah he's also got a bit part in
Terminator 2 Deena origins and we
pointed him out in the t2 on his trail
yeah easy why put that we did not write
breaking bed is made in the film I hope
your after Dean Norris Andrew Blanchard
writes fun fact the original line of
Richter's henchmen Marty was I'm sure
she hated every inch of it so I'm sure
she hated every minute of it is the line
that but again it's not the Bona or it's
just a bonus it was like good taste yes
no he does have a line addameer Segura
writes when will you make one for
Starship Troopers I mean I would love to
but like this is actually like one I
think the movies brilliant but it's also
on the surface so dumb so it's like it's
really hard for me to think of like what
the angle is because you could just
roast it like like it's not sort of self
aware I just think it is no it's very
challenged these are tough balances
because the movies are already you know
they're very smart and they're
self-aware and like that's what we're
kind of doing is them taking apart
things that aren't already self-aware
right now and Darth qeq rights
you forgot Richter had to see his wife
get nailed to get chewed out by his boss
then got widowed before to the man who
shot his wife
there it her and then shot her and and
then took your arms could happen worse
than then that's a pretty bad betrayal
so yeah both sleeps through your eyes
and then man takes your arms it's alive
at the bottom of that that thing doesn't
go up that high that's a lot of physical
trauma dreams none of its real wake up
back at space Chili's no he's not asleep
you think towards that his dream he
would just be at space Chili's good
point
all right well any more deep thoughts
and feelings about Total Recall 1990 I
just now hung grief or space chilly it's
a fun movie let's go to space Chili's
watch space balls watch baseball's yeah
that's still leave you with one thought
watch check that out and I'm told that
Dan has a very special clue for what
next week's honesty there will be well
it's tough because it's it's an easy one
to overlook but you don't want to so
yeah that's a good point yeah yeah yeah
oh maybe I shouldn't give one yeah
well there you go there you go that's
very very nicely done Dan all right
we'll see right here same time same
place
Australian commentaries thanks for
watching mommy
[Music]